what's up guys bang-bang don't we forgot
about lunch Monday today no we did not
just had to go get Polina from the
airport you have been retrieved
well washing try to get rich the rest of
us just trying to get our lunch money
right I'm here with the beautiful
intelligent plenum Air Nova who has the
right uniform on today thank God she's
late though to the recording that's fine
we'll deal with that problem later
don't forget response by block fine now
get money get paid three products buy
and sell crypto deposit crypto get a
u.s. dollar loan or my favorite product
as an investor and a user is to deposit
crypto or a stable coin and earn up to
eight point six percent APY woo long day
to day almost said the ad wrong block
five calm slash lunch money
go sign up what's up did you miss me
very much all right what's going on the
steam is packaged okay so by now most
Americans have already received their
stimulus money but now a second stimulus
package a second Simmons check may be
getting sent Trump he wants to send more
Trump books he said that he wants to
send another stimulus check directly to
the people he wants to be more than
$1,200 he claims to want to send more
than the Democrats want to send as you
know it's election year politician in
power wants to use all of their
resources to boost the economy give
money directly to the people you know
maybe just make themselves popular buy
some votes hey I have a question is
there a limit to how many executive
orders you are allowed no okay then
that's ridiculous because you can really
turn the presidency into like a
dictatorship real quick if I was
president I'd be like if I could have
ordered this is they could've worth of
that they can't why these are so slow
checks and balances like you could issue
a executive order and then somebody can
sue for example the travel ban if you
remember he issued an executive order on
a travel ban pre all the COBIT stuff
like for immigration and that and then
he went to court and actually some of
that guy overturn some of it didn't so
there's still checks and balances
takes a while of course it does but
there's still kind of a first who gets
the first shot across sorry as we're
recording one of my dogs is sitting here
now he has his paw on the table like he
has to be a part of this alright so
what's going on stimulus by the way
they're definitely gonna do more
stimulus both sides of the aisle want to
do more stimulus is the Republicans or
the Democrats they're gonna need to 45
plus million Americans have lost their
jobs as we've seen revenue for small
businesses and large corporations fall
off a cliff GDP is down to correct two
consecutive sessions of a contraction
GDP means a recession but stock markets
are all-time high baby speaking about
all-time highs in the stock market
what's up with my boy ezel casa is
crushing it and it's stock is soaring
it's sort of another nine percent on
Thursday after the company blew past
Wall Street's second quarter delivery
expectations the price is $1,200 now so
don't bet against innovation I've been
telling y'all by the way I own no Tessa
stock I got no horse in this race but
the fact that people keep shorting one
of the most innovative companies in the
world and by the way the best car
manufacturer in the United States in
terms of quality you guys are crazy
absolutely crazy and I'm so elated to
see Elon and the rest of the team
there's a whole team behind him just
absolutely short squeeze people remember
he was trading at $200 start was trained
at $200 and changed like 12 months ago
it's now 1,200 bucks what's up Tesla
said he'd deliver 90650 vehicles in the
quarter also did I see
I feel like yesterday I saw a red Tesla
- those exist yes why did he buy the 100
see that they're pretty see what happens
by the way Wall Street only thought they
were gonna deliver 72,000 they delivered
90,000 think about that for a second
that's all as one 20% more than wall she
was expecting of course bang bang stock
goes up when you beat expectations their
tournament turnin and burnin can't hate
on them it's built an awesome car yeah
look there's a tight financial situation
I get all of the reasons why not to to
be a fan or not to be a supporter
at the end of the day Tesla is the best
electric car on the market the world is
definitely gonna get more electric
rather than less and so if you want to
get in front of a steamroller
- - its reign is coming through it's
pretty amazing
created though cuz everyone when he was
update he's now laying on his back
wanted me to scratch his belly go ahead
he had his paw on the table with these
long nails all right
so I'm talking bad about him nothing bad
I'm saying I like his nail talking shape
now his paws in the air okay like
literally dog not like D aw gee like do
G dog I think I was saying it's pretty
cool what he's misc loss has created
given that nobody believed that an
electric car could could you could make
money off a business like that anyway
what's going on Andrew Luck got lucky
and Almer and ER L is that kind of
secretive defense tech company if you
Palmer Luckey Palmer Luckey who was
behind oculus is behind Andrew do you
like that how its lucky Palmer but
actually his name is Palmer Luckey yeah
but if you call him lucky Palmer it's
his name backwards you know like Oh
Palmer is lucky so lucky Palmer yeah
lucky pomp lucky lucky play actually
you're pretty lucky that I'm here that's
alright go ahead
you're lucky that I love you horse yeah
what's golfing wait before I get did you
miss me no not at all actually enjoyed
the peace and quiet around here
go ahead what's going on prove it and a
real raised 200 million in Series C
funding and around to led by andreessen
horowitz god there's so many
distractions here
led by andreessen horowitz in a
post-money valuation of 1.9 billion it
almost doubled its last funding round so
I did a bunch of research on mandrel I'm
familiar with them I think it's actually
really interesting and if you talk to
Trey what's his last name forgot his SM
he's the other founder Trace Stevens
there's five founders
tres Stevens I believe is his name basic
algorithm yeah basically they say that
still can valley or the government
should you know ask for a Silicon Valley
to help them with a lot of stuff they
just don't in America has been lacking
in innovation so this company it
actually helps the government what it's
true way it's a little bit more nuance
to that but yeah but it's true but
basically I think what their argument is
is first of all the government has is
super bureaucratic yeah is it on the
cutting edge of technology and they
should be not so much they should ask
Silicon Valley but just if you want to
use the cutting edges of technology it
happens to be that people from Silicon
Valley usually lead that course but the
second thing is and I think the more
important point is that the major tech
companies where most of the innovation
happens like Facebook Google etc they're
getting tons of pressure both internally
and externally not to work with the
government in defense I situations and
therefore there's now a new company that
specifically is going to use machine
learning AI computer vision and robotics
drones etc to go do this it's a little
controversial because you might have
seen in the news it says that integral
is helping the Trump administration
build a what are they calling it virtual
wall on the border
would you rather there be a real wall or
virtual I'm very Pro immigration but hot
to it okay
so but this is an important point can
you not be Pro immigration and also be
pro tight security at the border and
here's my reason why if you have most
immigrants most immigrants will actually
tell you that I'm an immigrant I know
and I think you agree this most people
will actually argue that it's unfair
that regardless of how they do it
certain people who skip the immigration
process and come to our country whether
it's on a boat whether they walk they
run they swim they do whatever from
wherever it's not just Mexico this is
could be from Canada could be from other
countries literally could float on a
raft from Cuba do whatever you want the
people who skip the line most immigrants
who have who have gone through the
process and done everything the right
way will say they actually believe in a
strong border from what I've had in
Congress
because they believe that well if I had
to wait in line why doesn't everybody
right but you're thinking of someone who
wasn't your grandparents came from Cuba
you know maybe one of them one of them
yeah the other ones came on a boat from
Italy but they went to Ellis Island they
went they stood in line they did the
process the guy from Cuba I think of
course oh I'm not saying by the way I'm
not saying that we shouldn't reform the
way that we do immigration but the
immigration process is broken and it can
be drastically improved
it could be streamlined it can become
more efficient more effective all of
that is true but what I think the
argument and again I'm talking about
people that are immigrants that I've
spoken to you know obviously I live with
one but for the most part the general
sentiment I get is like hey I'm with you
the immigration process why doesn't
everyone okay and and then the other
piece the only last thing I'll say is if
we are going to have tight security at
the borders
what do you agree with that or not and
you said to me choose between having a
dumb wall which is legs like a brick
wall or an iron gate or whatever the
hell it's gonna be or use technologies
like computer vision artificial
intelligence machine learning etc I
actually would prefer the technology
enabled one because it's gonna cost less
and it's actually gonna be more
effective but then you have gun-toting
drones would you rather have that I
don't I don't think that that's what
they're doing at the border they're not
ruling it out okay so they're not ruling
it out but I think what they're doing is
then that's more for combat situations
like they would rather send drones into
into actual combat that's not for
something at the border and the border I
think if they're focused more on things
like simply identifying the people who
are coming across the border yeah we can
have a whole lunch money dedicate on
this topic you just let the people know
do you agree or disagree on what I said
about immigrant beliefs in terms of
waiting through the process or not um I
think it really varies okay I don't
think it's it's not as black and white
no because the whole process sucks I
don't care how I got here everything
sucks I mean like we went through the
lottery program where you get a green
card first etc etc they misspelled your
name then mess up your Social Security
the onus like to become a citizen it is
an absurd process and the fact that I
don't know they did it to my family my
last name is not really popular honor if
you go far enough back we won't talk
about that
well we'll spend a whole didn't you at
one point tell me you would rather have
no borders human I believe neuro again
my belief is that you have to go one of
two ways either you over-rotate and you
say hey anyone can go anywhere in the
world there are no borders whatever that
introduces incredible issues around
governance and conflict and all that
kind of stuff but what you would get is
freedom of movement and kind of human
humanity gets all of the benefits of no
borders or you've got to go the other
way which is you've got to have strong
Wars everywhere and I don't think that
the u.s. is necessarily different than
most places what I think is very
different is that we have a process just
like every US plus our process is just
horrible as bureaucratic and ultimately
what we end up doing is we end up
unintentionally I believe but still we
end up incentivizing the rich and the
wealthy in other countries to come to
the u.s. not so much around just who's
the best qualified etc we've talked
about that I think I changed your mind
on that actually a little bit yeah okay
I just want smart cool people who are
chilled but you want problems don't be
coming here if you're not smart yeah
well we can even get away with that but
if you're coming here to start problems
or do anything crazy now we don't need
you most people I think are good people
alright so Hong Kong so try to figure
out if the bulgarians is a good person
okay let's just go on to Hong Kong you
don't think I'm gonna person I know
you're a good person you're a great
person actually come on Hong Kong pretty
before the dog how they gonna get up
won't be massacre they they know it's
getting awkward in here I told you guys
with the first arrests under the law
they arrested 400 people Hey
we don't need all that noise we're
trying to do some work over here guys
can you guys chill out let us do our
work okay thank you
all right you're gonna die okay so four
hundred people
Hong Kong were arrested after this after
police are moving swiftly to enforce
China's new national security rule keep
the people back their freedom China this
is screwed up I don't agree with the
security law basically what it allows
you to do is now China can determine
anyone who is against the country of
China do a whole bunch of different
means they can go and they can arrest
them they can extradite them back to
China this introduces all kinds of
problems one it takes away the
sovereignty of Hong Kong two it takes
away the freedom of the Hong Kong people
three introduces the idea that the
Chinese government is now going to be
able to put their dictatorship in there
communism onto the people of Hong Kong
it's gonna increase the surveillance
state and five actually what I think is
the worst part about all this is this is
China's way to try to elicit a response
from people in the global economy
because Hong Kong is considered one of
the international finance hubs now all
of a sudden that that is compromised you
now are gonna see tons of companies flee
or in some types of private citizens
flee in a and it's gonna introduce a lot
of cops do we think that the US
companies that do business in Hong Kong
are gonna pull out yeah of course
because now that now it's like based
having a business in China right there's
literally one of the stories I've read
is a guy just simply had a flag he was
sending it holding a flag that said like
free the Hong Kong people or something
like very kind of non-controversial in
the sense of he was standing up for what
in a democratic area which is because
they're a protest he was arrested and he
could have done something else I don't
know that I have all the facts but just
the fact that this now allows him to
extradite people I think is a slippery
slope
I feel for people Hong Kong this is not
good it's not good for the people in
Hong Kong there's also not good people
global company I'm just gonna say I'm
glad they're protesting I think that
what I feel we're radicalizing polina no
no I've always been radicalized about
this stuff I think I think the people
want democracy you promised them a
democracy you deliver democracy ok MPA I
was going you just hand chocolates no
huge Oh or did you pork chop us I was
going to NBA
come on come on ok so I don't know
what's going on actually he just made me
put this on your there's a bubble
they're all going to Orlando
they created a bubble in that bubble
basically the players and the staff and
the coach is off to stay inside the
bubble no one's allowed in or out look
that's that's how basically think of it
as a bubble is like hey everyone's gonna
go in this area
and no one's go out in or out so that's
how they're gonna ferment the
coronavirus physical place so people are
obviously just gonna walk in and start
talking about it that's fine too dogs
are gonna bark they're gonna look at us
like we're crazy but they're the idiots
it's fine and so ends up what is going
to happen is basically people are either
gonna be allowed them not or they're not
the physical space yeah like everyone's
going to Orlando on in Disneyworld and
nothing around but the players are
saying that it's unlikely that they're
going to abide by that and the part that
I think is the best argument I've seen
it is Steven age Steven a Smith went on
television it was like listen you're
gonna tell me that a bunch of grown-ass
testosterone weighted men are not gonna
go try to hang out with their wives or
their girlfriends for for number of
weeks I mean he's just like that ain't
gonna happen
I'm just telling you right now that
ain't gonna happen I tend to agree with
him stay in your bubble
speaking of some of you should have
stayed in her bubble but she came to the
US you got arrested
Galyna Maxwell is the partner in crime
to Jeffrey Epstein
I think terrible terrible person all
around based on what I know but she was
arrested Thursday morning in New
Hampshire I don't know what the hell she
was doing in New Hampshire but she was
basically the the woman who helped
Epstein run his ring of young girls I'm
calling it right now I want to get ahead
of the curve gizelle ghilane Maxwell did
not kill herself I'm calling it right
now she ain't kill herself it means that
she's gonna end up dead I don't know how
yet I don't know when but she didn't
kill herself all right be quiet okay so
next can we talk about hold us again
just so we're clear Jeffrey epsy didn't
kill himself either so I just want to
make sure that we're all clear on all of
that come on get out of here oh the
cameras didn't work the security guards
were sleeping come on don't don't feed
me the [ __ ] I need ya almost say is
that for one second of all I'm glad they
caught her third of all she's got a lot
of questions to answer
affordable actually there's a lot of
really powerful people who apply
scumbags who if she talks she's gonna
expose him
we watched the Epstein documentary on
Netflix and he got super mad at it or
not the not the documentary yet what was
allowed to happen for years on end if I
have a daughter here's a message all the
Predators don't even try don't even try
it
yo might as well just warm up my cell
right now don't even try it alright
what's going on with a fainting dog's
fainting dogs do you know what that's
about
No so I'm assuming they pass out
apparently yes so apparently that was
dogs like humans have you know an
instinct to be afraid of really loud
bangs and sounds and noises and so
apparently one of the things is that on
4th of July a lot of dogs actually faint
from the fireworks yeah we think I
secure the fireworks by the way I have
no equity in this I have no referral fee
I have no advertising with them but a
company in Durham North Carolina near
where I grew up they created the Thunder
shirt and the Thunder shirt is a shirt
that you put on the dog that wraps them
really tightly
whatever blanket have you blanket for
dogs yeah the basic it basically makes
them feel safer when there's fireworks
when there's thunder loud noises
whatever so if you got a dog fourth of
July is coming probably too late now but
go get you a thunder shirt a little
puppy that runs around oh yeah but and
then a half the other dogs just faint
okay all right give us a joke hurry up
50 seconds I got 6% left on my computer
hurry hurry hurry
did you hear about the claustrophobic
astronaut yeah he he was out of space ah
close he just needed a little bit of
space it's not that funny cuz like if I
can get it is dumping not funny alright
guys that's it for lunch Monday today
well while she's trying to get rich the
rest of us is just trying to get our
lunch money right
hopefully tomorrow no dogs no humans
just let's to see unit humans bang bang
hope you guys enjoyed this episode of
lunch money as much as we did
don't forget lunch monies now sponsored
by block 5 so go check them out there's
a link in the
trypsin that you can click on I'm an
investor a user and a huge fan what
you're a bigger fan of block fire than
you are of me block lies my second
favorite thing in the world behind
Polina
they've got three products they can give
you a US dollar loan you can earn up to
eight point six percent interest on an
interest-bearing account or you can buy
and sell crypto currencies on their
crypto exchange I personally use the
interest-bearing account there's not
very many places where you'll find up to
eight point six percent interest on a
deposit in an interest-bearing account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but eight point six percent
it's pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks that block by subscribe to our
channel like the video annoy playin in
the comment and we'll see you guys
tomorrow and be kind to your friends